philadelphia eagles carson wentz out
doug peterson out jalen hurts in at
least for now is the quarterback
multiple teams have interest in zach
ertz also reports that they're
considering trading brandon brooks who
missed all of last year with uh
torn achilles i believe it was that was
suffered before training camp
uh is any team going to have a different
set of offensive weapons a more
different set of offensive weapons than
the eagles this year i mean it's just a
matter of time before sean jeffrey's
gone
deshawn jackson's gone zach ertz is
going to be gone we're not going to
recognize
this eagles team no they need it it
needs to be blown up i mean
there's no doubt there's nothing there's
nothing to hang on to anymore they
totally need to rebuild restructure
do it all i'm not surprised to hear
about zach ertz at all
you know he doesn't block all that well
there's not a lot of yards after catch
he's one of those things he's going to
want a new contract that seems like here
right he's got what was it one more year
left on his deal i thought maybe i'm
i'm wrong there um but but
they got a dallas goddard who went
healthy is the best tight end on their
football team
so i'm not shocked to hear zachary's you
know being being put out there on the
trade market
definitely but they need everything you
know
yeah they need updates to the receiver
we'll see how the first rounder did last
you know jalen rieger can he improve
it wasn't all that impressive in year
one and then the quarterback situation
of course is huge i mean yeah we know we
got the defensive issues and
there's gonna be some stuff there they
could use another pass rusher for sure
their middle linebacker play their
linebackers it's not special at all
there
uh but but the quarterback's really the
thing you look at
and what do they do just sitting there
at number six are they gonna ride with
jalen hurts
or are they gonna try to make a move get
a quarterback at number six
and try to build something with nick
ciriani and that type of offense jalen
hurts definitely doesn't fit what nick
ciriani wants to do
that's the big thing so i don't know
where this goes mike and i don't know if
i
what what's your gut tell you do you
think they're going to be in the market
for quarterback at number six this year
are they going to try to kind of
like wait a year you think they are yeah
i think they're going to have a second
guy
yeah who is going to compete with jalen
hurts and potentially could start in
place of jalen hurts and
i don't know what they're in the midst
of i don't know what to call this that
the eagles are doing i can't think of a
team that has disintegrated its roster
and coaching staff faster yeah after
winning a super bowl than the eagles
it's amazing to see what's happened and
uh it feels like it's got a bottom out
before it it starts to go in the other
direction and i don't think they've hit
bottom
yet hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports